on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour parler
d'un sujet dont je voulais vous parler
depuis déjà un bon moment ça fait aller
quasiment en or c'est le fair use moi je
suis installé ici dans ce studio à paris
pas très loin du père lachaise et j'ai
pas pris le temps de vous faire une
vidéo set-up pourquoi tout simplement
parce que tout n'était pas encore prêt
pas installé aujourd'hui c'est quasiment
chose faite il reste pas grand chose
mais je me suis dit qu'il fallait quand
même commencer à vous faire cette vidéo
set up sur vous présenter mon studio les
différents endroits où j'ai dû matériel
à quoi ils me servent qu'est-ce que j'en
fais et je posterai régulièrement
d'autres vidéos en vous parlant de
l'évolution parce que je sais pas si
vous le savez mais il ya mon studio ici
à paris j'ai aussi mon studio chez moi j
ai donc deux set up et avec le
confinement et j'ai dû booster le set up
chez moi donc tout n'est pas ici en tout
cas une partie du set up qui est
vraiment doublé mais avant toute chose
c'est pas déjà fait je vous invite à
venir vous abonner pourquoi parce que je
vous parle de take vous parle de
nouveautés de smartphones deux mondes
deux tablettes d'ordinateurs de tout ça
est bien évidemment votre délit mairie
donc si ce n'est pas déjà fait vous
allez cliquer sur le petit bouton sous
vous actionnez la cloche comme ça vous
saurez tout le premier endroit c'est mon
espace bureau c'est là où je travaille
comme d'habitude je dirais que bien peu
de bazar c'est ce qui me définit est
toujours un peu de bazar un peu
d'imprécisions dans beaucoup de
précision avec quelques cartons avec des
passages de câbles qui sont pas
complètement parfaitement maîtrisé mais
c'est pas très grave
quand elle s'adressera de quoi optimiser
le studio et vous faire de cette vidéo
un peu plus tard je crois que tout le
plus important quand on veut avoir un
bon studio est un bon endroit pour
travailler c'est d'avoir une bonne
assise c'est supra important parce que
si vous n'avez pas une bonne assise vous
risquez de vous faire mal au dos vous
n'êtes pas bien proposé pas dans de
bonnes conditions ici là j'ai un truc
qui est vraiment extrêmement confortable
c'est une chaise de rect c'est la r go
alors je vous ai déjà présenté la r go
max il ya quelques mois d'ailleurs j'ai
mis le lien dans l'inscription
allez jeter un petit coup d'oeil mais ce
qui est chouette c'est déjà une
sensation de robustesse en termes de
confort on est vachement bien peu le
calicot mont ventoux complètement la
personnaliser là c'est la r go elle leur
fait un peu moins que la maxe mais elle
aiderait non stop des trucs qui est
vraiment important c'est toute la partie
du dos toute la partie de soutien des
lombaires ici vous avez un vrai gars on
est vraiment bien maintenue il ya un
côté un peu rebondi ça ajoute vraiment
confort et c'est vraiment extrêmement
appréciable
en ce qui me concerne je monte sur final
cut pro du coup je suis sous mac
j'aime beaucoup les marques travaillent
dessus depuis très longtemps l'âge est
le dernier modèle g le macbook
process pouces c'est pas tant la taille
de l'écran qui fait la différence mais
surtout ce qu'on peut faire avec et
notamment ce qui m'a vraiment bluffé
c'est toute la partie audio avec une
excellente spatialisation ça quand vous
posez c'est génial tout ça c'est très
cool mais je n'utilise pas le dieu du
mak sauf quand je suis en déplacement
pour travailler pour faire du montage
non ce que j'utilise c'est ça ça c'est
une enceinte ya mascella mxn 500 et ça
croyez moi c'est une vraie petite tuerie
dans mon set up je crois que c'est un
des éléments que je préfère pourquoi
déjà parce que j'ai un côté un peu
affectif avec yamaha quand j'étais
assistant studio il ya très longtemps
ce travail sur dns 10 c'est vraiment pas
du tout la même chose sur des moniteurs
de studio le son est très plat c'est pas
du tout fait pour l'utiliser de la même
manière là dessus on n'est pas du tout
sur un moniteur de studio extrêmement
plat ont fait effectivement du
monitoring on est vraiment sur un
produit de hi-fi et si vous allez voir
un tweeter à dôme nous trois centimètres
en bouffeurs de 13 cm une enceinte qui
est vraiment basée sur la collectivité
c'est un produit vous pouvoir connecter
directement à votre box vous êtes au
pouvoir castet depuis votre smartphone
votre pc votre mac votre nas votre délai
vous pouvez également la connecter en
bluetooth elle est compatible apple
airplay
vous avez également une sortie optique
vous avez vous même votre prise lane
pour bien la branche et c'est un produit
qui est vraiment génial vous avez deux
amplis séparer un ampli pour votre
twitter est un ampli pour votre routeur
et surtout elle et multicast et ça vous
donne un résultat qui est vraiment mais
vraiment très très très bon alors pour
elle ou lui faire écouter mais comme ça
ça va pas rentrer j'ai un très bon petit
micro comme ça ça va être extraordinaire
la qualité est là et surtout le côté
musique cas ce qui est vraiment bien
leur musique asapistra dans l'écosystème
faire du multi room
ça dépend vous ça dépend de votre config
ça dépend ce que vous voulez en faire
mais pour moi ce qu'il faut vraiment
retenir avec 6 enceintes
déjà c'est la qualité audio c'est la
connectivité vous le connecter à tout ce
que vous voulez et en plus vous avez
même une petite télécommande tout en
naîtra d'activer le bluetooth que vous
voulez enfin voila moi je trouve ça
vraiment cool vraiment bien si vous
recherchez des enceintes de bonne
qualité vous pouvez aller sur les yamaha
enix n500 elle coûte un certain budget
799 euros la paire mais par contre une
fois vous les aurez banco vous aurez
vraiment un produit qui super bien aux
peaux qui est extrêmement important pour
moi pour la vidéo c'est le fait d'avoir
un moniteur de qualité pour pouvoir
bosser je travaille quasiment tout le
temps sur mon écran 16 pouces
lorsque je suis ici je prends vraiment
plaisir pouvoir bosser sur deux écrans à
la fois ici j'ai un moniteur de philips
brilliance c'est la gamme la référence c
est le 329 pdf c'est un moniteur de 32
quatre caches des 3840 x 2160 pixels moi
ici je finis le brancher en usb cd vous
avez deux ports hdmi si vous le
souhaitez à une époque j'ai utilisé
cette webcam de logitech mais j'en ai
une qui est très cool et que j'ai pas eu
le temps de tester à cause du
confinement
je voulais à ramener mais voyez voyez
confinement faisant j'ai pas pu sortir
mon produit et maintenant je suis un peu
décalé par rapport à l'actuelle à stream
cam de logitech
ça s'est vu tourner lors d'un brief et
ça s'est vraiment bien donc si vous
voulez stream et que voulant prendre de
bonne qualité celle là je vous la
conseille parce que elle va vraiment
devenir s'adapter à vous au fait vous
bougiez il ya pas mal d'options et c'est
un produit qui est très très très cool
autre produit qui est très court et que
j'aime bien installé ses salles à simon
google l'est loeb c'est comme un google
l'est sauf que celui là bas et il a
l'image s'affiche plein de photos de
souvenirs c'est mon assistant
intelligent j'ai une petite caméra
surveillance de shiomi qui fait très
bien la faire ci tournait beaucoup de
choses aussi le 2 temps de roulage mais
la caméra derrière une question que je
me pose toujours
c'est comment est ce que je fais pour
est toujours temps bordélique ça permet
d'avoir des plans avec de la profondeur
sur la vue fort studio de leur côté là
j'ai tout ça en arrière plan et c'est
très cool parce qu'en plus j'ai la
fenêtre là c'est mieux pour mes yeux le
fait d'avoir aussi la lumière du jour de
ce côté là et quand j'ai tourné des
vidéos j'ai un petit renfort d'éclairage
grâce à la lumière du jour mais en plus
gênés 2 panneaux d'éclairage sur le côté
parce qu'en ce moment je tourne avec
salaces et des panneaux s'est dessinée
rohi death et des tout petits panneaux
qui sont très cools qui diffuse plutôt
bien signer rohit c'est les fl 400 je
vais régler la température de couleur je
vais régler mon intensité et ensuite je
cours l'autre côté j'ai branché j'ai
exactement le même de l'autre côté j'en
ai deux en fait peut-être que je vais
changer pour de la future pour l'instant
je suis là dessus ça c'est pratique le
seul truc qu'il manque un peu c'est que
regarder c'est le câble et moi je tout
le temps en train de déplacer mon matos
tout le temps en train de bouger dont je
voudrais me prendre une petite batterie
que je viendrais mètres derrière ça je
le prendrais je le garderais là dessus
je pourrais déplacer mes pieds beaucoup
plus facilement vous êtes au courant
tout est d'ailleurs puisque je vous
parle d'éclairage ici j'ai éclairé le
studio avec du philips ue s'est encore
complètement fini il ya encore des
choses à améliorer a rajouté mais d'un
point de vue purement ambiance c'est
vraiment très très bon sur le bureau ça
permet d'avoir une petite lampe toute
mignonne et si vous venez dans le coin
s'allonger cet éclairage là cet
éclairage l'âge et l'éclairage qui est
en dessous du canapé ça c'est un bandeau
extérieur en fait c'est ce qui au
conseil pour l'extérieur et qu'on peut
venir utiliser pour mettre ses meubles
et ça c'est vraiment très très content
parce que ça vous le souligner et là
j'ai le bandeau à l'aide d'intérieur que
j'ai mise
derrière et qui viennent souligner un
petit peu le mur et qu'il ya vraiment un
effet très sympa et de la de côté ici
sous la télé j'ai aussi cette espèce de
petit d'homme qui est très cool et tout
ça je viens de piloter avec ma
télécommande c'est à dire que je viens
l'éteindre où je viens là lui mais j'ai
un pont le pour philippe ciu qui est
planqué ici qui est tombé d'ailleurs qui
est juste là et qui est branché sur ma
nouvelle box de bouygues telecom dont je
vous ai déjà parlé d'ailleurs je vous
renvoie la vidéo pour tout savoir et
d'ailleurs j'ai aussi ce tableau là je
peux venir changer les couleurs très
facilement envoyer change l'ambiance ça
je vous l'avais montré qu'on avait fait
une vidéo avec philippe chouvou meliana
la description si ça c'était vraiment
très très très cool vous allez à votre
éclairage qui va changer en cours sur de
la musique autre endroit qui est très
très cool c'est la partie ici alors ici
en fait vous ne voyez pas vraiment comme
ça c'est une table sur laquelle j'ai
filmé tous les plans du dessus entre s20
et le s20 plus vous avez une différence
de forme
j'ai la caméra qui vient se fixer juste
ici quand vous voyez mes mains en train
de manipuler des produits c'est que je
suis ici en tout cas quand je suis à
paris là j'ai un pied girafe avenger qui
me parlent effectué à positionner la
caméra dessus que ça c'est du solide
s'inscrit la taille de la poignée par
moi j'utilise aussi un petit peu comme
un porte manteau de sacs tellement de
sac quand on fait des événements ici que
je sais même plus quoi faire et j'ai un
contrepoids qui énorme de 6,7 kg pour
être très précis pour éviter que sa
bouche et croyez moi ça ne bouge
absolument pas maintenant le seul truc
ici c'est que quand je pose ma caméra
tac tac
elle est fixée eh bien je vois rien
parce que l'écran moniteur je le vois
pas du coup j'utilise ça ça c'est un
petit moniteur c'est bien marc heno
ressemblant comme le port salut shinobi
adomos je viens le branché en hdmi
ça me permet de voir moi directement où
j'en suis ce que je fais et au passage à
spéciale dédicace style panther groupe
de glam au rock
ils sont magnifiques élément ressort
plutôt fun mort à côté j'ai un petit
tableau avec un petit clin d'oeil à la
french tech et d'ailleurs cette astuce
si ça vous intéresse si vous voulez
faire un setup comme ça le petit bras là
que j'ai utilisée pour venir le poser
pour venir l'accroché ça n'a rien à voir
là tomo sinobi ça c'est le brader petit
enregistreur vous ça c'est le zoom hmr
il ya un autre point qui est extrêmement
important pour moi c'est le côté podcast
est ici c'est le troisième espace c'est
l'espace podcast alors truc un peu
schizophrénique parce qu en fait
l'espace podcast je n'ai pas utilisé
pour enregistrer les podcasts pourquoi
parce que j'enregistrais les podcasts
juste à la fin du confinement et que
j'étais pas encore revenue sur paris
donc tout ça ce beau matos et bien je
n'ai pas encore utilisé
doubler mon set up et je les améliorer
ici j'ai utilisé une des références en
termes de broadcast pour le micro c'est
le jour s n 7 b ce qui est bien avec ce
micro c'est tout d'abord la façon dont
il est fabriqué vous pouvez venir
l'enlever pour vous en rendre compte
vous avez votre capteur qui est situé
juste là ça vient vraiment la tipp et
des fabrications qui vraiment très
particulière à vous avez choix entre
deux bonnes est soit cette bonne est là
qui est un peu la bonette de base qu'on
trouve un peu partout
soit une deuxième bonne est qui est
beaucoup plus épaisses faut vraiment
venir lui parler d'eux dans va jouer le
rôle de filtre anti pop
bonjour à tous comment vous allez bien
j'espère ça se passe bien
personnellement j'adore ce micro parce
qu'il est extrêmement typés et qu'il
était vraiment une super voix alors si
c'est du micro dynamique c'est un bonne
alimentation fantôme et en plus vous
avez un réglage de coupe bat de paso les
deux parce que je voulais faire des
podcasts avec des invités ça arrivera
mais un peu plus tard
est ce que j'avais prévu initialement
cette petite interface la cla scarlett
de phocuswright qui est vraiment très
très cool pour venir enregistrer
j'ai deux entrées micro je me plais ici
est au dessus j'ai un petit ampli pour
casque ou et m quatre casques ça c'est
mon set up de base mais quand j'ai
acheté saron n'avait pas encore sorti
son road caster pro qui est sam x est
pour les podcasts et qui est un petit
bijou j'en ai déjà parlé plusieurs fois
dans différentes vidéos
j'ai pas fait de vidéos dédiées dessus
mais vous en trouverez sur le web très
très facilement c'est un produit qui est
beaucoup plus adapté donc je pense que
ça je vais le garder pour faire de la
musique à côté mais je vais rapatrier le
roadster pro ici et je ferai tout mais
podcast ici avec north 14 points
d'ailleurs en parlant ça j'ai doublé mon
set up peut-être que je vais doubler
l'europe caster pro je sais pas je vais
voir comment je vais faire parce que
j'ai également sm7 b chez moi j'ai
l'hérault caster pro et c'est
extrêmement simple et c'est beaucoup
plus simple que ça passe que vous
enregistrez tous directement sur votre
cas je tourne dans des conditions du
direct et ensuite je peux envoyer et le
mettre directement au podcast ça m'évite
d'avoir à faire du montage et c'est un
vrai gain de temps alors ça vous oblige
par contre à être extrêmement précis et
extrêmement concis moment vous tournez
vous n'avez pas de filet quand l'erreur
est dit et fait
eh bien on peut parvenir à corriger mais
ça apporte aussi beaucoup de spontanéité
et c'est vraiment un truc que j'adore
d'heures si vous n'avez pas vu le
podcast je vous mets le lien en bas à
l'échec ou d'ailleurs pourquoi si vous
n'avez pas écouté puisque c'est pas de
la vidéo
allez jeter un petit coup d'oeil ça fait
vraiment très très cool par contre j'ai
gardé exactement la même config au
niveau du pied c'est les petits pierrots
qui sont vraiment adaptée ça vient
contrebalancer en fait le poids du micro
ce qui fait que vous le mettez comme
vous voulez vous déplacez à patrick est
vraiment génial services attachés sur
une table c'est vraiment très pratique
pas notre truc que j'ai gardées g
comment la même chose chez moi c'est ses
cascades meilleure dynamique seller
d'été sept ans soixante dix pros ça
c'est la version 250 hommes alors je
vais vous passez un peu côté technique
ça marche très bien
vous avez une bonne tenue d'oreille il
ya une bonne qualité audio
c'est un casque on retrouve beaucoup ce
soit en radio ou en studio et qui est
vraiment une des références dans son
domaine et qui surtout extrêmement
confortable au niveau des petits
coussinets j'ai mon trophée des sens car
ça c'est très très cool j'ai un google
phone ce n'est pas google l'est à
l'époque c'est vraiment un google ou
amazon avec ça et là j'ai un tableau qui
a été fait par l'un d'entre vous et je
remercie encore j'ai mangé pendant tu
m'excuseras j'ai un peu honte je suis
très heureux que tu m'as fait ce tableau
parce que voyez il trône directement sur
ma table et c'est une super création qui
est fait à partir de collages découpages
bas que je trouve vraiment super sympa
quand je vous parlais d'imperfections on
y est directement ma passion de produits
mais sur le fronton de le ranger
il me faut un petit meuble ici pour
mettre vraiment la boxe pour mettre le
nas
j'ai un petit nas de western digital
c'est le p r 4100 j'ai 4 x 4 terra g16
terrain en tout et il est vraiment
divisé en deux parties
ici c'est un endroit vous avez aussi
beaucoup vu dans différentes vidéos
c'est le côté salon d'ailleurs un sujet
on va agrandir un petit peu j'ai un
nouvel objectif que j'étais encore testé
ici c'est celui qu'utilise manque au
dojo le c-17 14 garder le temps de
changer ça change un petit peu de fuir
et l'idée ici c'est effectivement là
c'est dans l'univers que j'aime bien
c'est l'univers rock on va retrouver des
grandes références
je vous ai mis que des affiches de
dengue et surtour des affiches
originales d'ailleurs dit mon
commentaire si vous arrivez deviner
laquelle n'est pas une affiche originale
marqué le haut en bas
l'idée de cet endroit là c'est vraiment
d'avoir un coin qui me ressemble très
rock
un côté un peu plus longue aussi et
surtout à côté salon parce qu'ici je
suis très très très cool pour me
regarder la télé alors c'est une annonce
elle quatre cas j'en ai déjà parlé ces
modèles de l'année dernière de lg 55
pouces de pur bonheur ces temps de
revenir tester mes nouvelles télés très
très très facilement et puis on se
voyait
je vous ai mis une anciens que j'ai
également testé
[Musique]
ça c'est un petit jeu d'apéro que j'ai
pas encore ouvert un petit klaxons une
petite borne d'arcade et j'ai aussi une
grande bande d'arcade et avant de vous
la montrer j'ai ici mon la zone de
stockage ou devient ranger les
différents produits
il ya quelques smartphones qui traîne il
ya un peu de tout voilà c'est un peu le
bazar il ya beaucoup de produits green
oscille il ya de l'eau diouf c'est un
peu le bordel
il ya des produits d'entretien tout ce
mélange il a juste à côté de la porte
j'ai quelques petits badges en plus de
ce que j'ai chez moi et j'ai une
trottinette de segway pour me balader
dans paris qui était très cool et j'ai
salah qui est fabriqué par skype aphtes
ça s'est vraiment bien parce que je met
mon smartphone
l'étui bière en plastique reste
complètement tactile léman est vraiment
très puissant vous glissez salah comme
ça qui dit studio dit aussi entretien du
studio et pour ça tu utilises un produit
que je vous ai déjà présenté qui est
juste là ok là voyez c'est l'aspirateur
robot rock c'est le s5
et quand je vous dis que j'utilise
l'aspirateur robot rov c'est pas une
blague
j'ai beaucoup j'ai lu s5 là j'en ai
panneaux d un jaune pâle prochainement
de votre aspirateur robot rock mais le
clou du spectacle c'est ça c'est la
bande arcade monsieur grrrr et ça c'est
juste un truc de fou j'en ai rêvé
pendant longtemps d'avoir une ben barka
n'a pas forcément mieux ce groupe est
d'avoir une borne d'arcade et le rêve a
été rendue possible grâce à la société
française qui s'appelle flex arcade ce
mix arcade ça c'est de l'installation
c'est quand même assez long la vache la
lumière j'adore d'elle ok je tombe sur
wendel c'est un écran d'ordinateur la
base c'est le seul moyen d'avoir des
écrans qu'à tiers en fait ok je fais
plus les cafetières guen avec ses
arcades
j'aime bien et c'est quoi ce bouton
c'est le volume ainsi le volume ok ça
les haut parleurs ici en fait pour moi y
est je suis une ville jeu mais là ça va
être dur travail et la voiture de faire
le tour du jardin voit comme un ancien
août a atteint bouton crédit je me donne
à des pièces qu'ils voient sur tu peux
si tu veux ou fonctions que j'ai fait
remettre des pièces et en fait vous flex
arcade vous faites des bornes plus pour
professionnels oui à la base c'était
orienté pour les professionnels mais je
vois en tant que ça intéresse beaucoup
les partir du génie ces menaces et des
gens croient que je lis à elle avec un
baby foot
hyperactive heures on peut vous trouver
ou du coup sur internet sur internet on
a un site fait que sa requête point fr
ouest à g facebook tu joues aquamax wall
street hockey qui tombe à 15 h 15 le
meilleur je veux dire c'est de l'époque
ça combien de personnes était né bah moi
j'avais 15 ans ah oui là j'avais 15 ans
voyons ils m'ont fabriquer une brosse
d'arcade complètement sur mesure un peu
schizophrénique avec que des photos de
moi voyez la photo avec lewis hamilton
c'est vachement cool plein d'autres
photos de l'autre côté plein de
souvenirs toutes les consoles que je
j'ai plein de jeux je peux jouer la game
boy je peux jouer la master system à la
super nintendo et la playstation
ça craque vraiment très très fort entre
eux de jouer à deux vous avez six
boutons vous avez votre joystick
le truc est absolument incroyable donc
ça veut dire que je ne travaille
je fais mes vidéos gelé tout rond de
face dans la partie salon je lis tourner
dans la camp il n'y a pas la borne il
faut j'étais d'ailleurs une petite place
à cette bande marcal je m'en suis tout
monté d'un côté buron j'ai les podcasts
bon pour l'instant ça s'organise pas
trop là mais ça va finir par arriver là
terme et ensuite quand j'en ai marre et
que je me détendre un peu
j'ai la partie pendant d'arcalis et ce
qu'ils m'ont juste c'est je dirai au
réfrigérateur pendant débats sont
fraîches et puis sinon on est quand même
plutôt pas mal donc voilà pour cette
première version du studio il ya plein
de nouvelles choses à venir et y être
que je vous ai pas encore montré je
voulais montrer très rapidement dans
pareils prochaine fois est ce que vous
connaissez les produits de l'anneau
leafs et objets de décoration qui sont
complètement interactif vous pouvez
faire de soi peu plus complexe de toutes
les couleurs et je suis très heureux
parce que ici j'en ai pas moins de 280 4
derrière j'ai le mur complet en fait
alors je sais pas si vous en rendrez
compte comme ça sa part de tout là haut
ça va jusqu'à tout en bas il y en a en
tout 280 4 ça va me faire un mur lumière
absolument incroyable support mire le
paramétrer faire des pac man est un pas
mal de choses ça va être ou sajoo
montrerait très très très très
prochainement suis en train de finir le
set up là pour l'instant c'est encore un
peu le bordel voyeur il faut trouver les
cris citer tous les côtés il y en a ici
il y en a ici et ça ça fonctionnera très
très très bientôt et croyez moi ça va
vraiment envoyer du bois
voilà pour cette première vidéo setup on
est aujourd'hui en juillet 2020 j'en
ferai d'autres va y avoir des évolutions
jour paraît bien évidemment des quatre
valdano leaf
il y aura plein de choses qui vont
arriver qu'ils vont évoluer je pense qu
aura pas mal de belles surprises ça va
dépendre reste l'année de ce qui va se
passer par rapport au courant des russes
mais je pense que normalement il voyant
des choses assez intéressante sur ce je
vous embrasse vous invite à vous abonner
à dire vous ce que vous pensez qu est ce
que vous pensez qu'il faudrait améliorer
dans le studio
sk des choses que vous verriez un peu
différemment au niveau de la répartition
des espaces au niveau de ce que je vous
ai montré n'hésitez pas à laisser tout
cela en bas en commentaire quant à vous
je vous embrasse au rendez vous dès
demain pour continuer par le tech ou des
bisous ciao ciao
[Musique]